Hey youtubers it’s charlie and it’s time
to take one last bow, sherlock’s time is
over now. His last vow just aired and there
are so many things to talk about in addition
to series 4 which they’ve already started
working on.
If you didn’t see my videos for the previous
episodes, this video will be a non-spoilery
review of his last vow. Then tomorrow I’ll
be doing a q&a video where I answer specific
questions you guys have about the episode
and then the day after that I’ll post a
detailed breakdown of the episode with all
the canon references and interesting facts
about the story. Be sure to subscribe to get
everything.
Since this was the last episode I’ll also
be doing a series 4 video the same day I post
that breakdown video.
So here are my top 5 favorite things about
His Last Vow. Number 5 - The Comedy. The episode
is a really intense drama, you have a villain,
sherlock and watson. and the threat that someone
is definitely going to die at the end. The
actual pull quote from the trailer for the
episode was “Sometimes someone has to die.”
But some of the funniest sherlock moments
come from the characters status as high functioning
sociopath.
A normal person like Watson gets really intense
during all the most dramatic moments, but
somehow sherlock still manages to slip in
a subtle turn of phrase and it’s laugh out
loud funny.
On the other side of that coin, some of the
funniest moments in the episode come when
character express geniune sentiment towards
Sherlock and he recoils in fear.
I feel like it’s only a matter of time before
we see a high functioning sociopath stand
up comedy tour. It will just be sherlock walking
up to people saying awful things.
Number 4 - Mycroft. He’s one of the strangest
holmes characters. And even though he’s
supposed to be very emotionally distant. Mark
Gatiss still manages to surprise you with
some warmth and genuine emotion. There were
some amazing scenes between sherlock and mycroft
that invoked a lot of holmes boys comedy.
The episode gives you a lot of context for
why Mycroft behaves the way he does.
There were a few scenes that I actually though
Mark Gatiss stole from Benedict Cumberbatch,
that’s how good he was. Typically people
only see sherlock when he’s on screen, so
you can forget sometimes that Mark Gatiss
is largely responsible for the dialogue given
to cumberbatch. So he’s really the most
clever person on the set.
Number 3 - The canon references. This episode
has way more canon than empty hearse or sign
of three. Even if you haven’t read any of
the novels recently you get a sense of the
importance of places and events. One of the
things I really like about adapted stories
is the opportunity to explore episodes over
time. Nothing in the series is included in
the scripts or things in the set design and
locations without subtle meaning.
Sherlock had this really amazing line in Sign
of Three where he says the universe is rarely
so lazy. And it’s just a metaphor for the
idea that everything is connected and there
are no coincidences.
Number 2 - The Villain. Lars Mikkelsen is
definitely a worthy successor to Andrew Scott’s
Moriarty. Holmes cannon is so vast that there’s
always more villains to pull off the page,
but it’s really the actors that are responsible
for making them feel like a credible threat
to Sherlock.
One of the differences between the Magnussen
character and the moriarty character that
I really liked was the absence of passion.
Moriarty was a force of pure emotion. He was
the little kid on the playground that just
liked smashing other kids toys. But magnussen
is a self-described businessman. Just acquiring
and selling assets. If we’re living in the
information age, then he’s like the ultimate
stock trader.
and my number 1 favorite - the hero’s journey.
What I mean when I say that is Sherlock’s
journey. It’s the same journey from episode
1 to now. Sherlock in exile or hell clawing
his way back to heaven. His version of heaven
anyway. I saw a lot of you guys commenting
on the big changes sherlock was going through
in each episode this series. I just think
it was sherlock slowly healing himself. He
was broken, team sherlock was broken and it
takes an entire series to put everything back
together so they can go on and have more adventures.
The ending of this episode in particular gives
you the sense that there will always be more
sherlock, because we as fans need him. and
Because in the context of the story england
will always need him.
I guess that does make him kind of a time
lord. Just regenerating himself every time
one adventure ends and another begins.
Now it’s your turn to let me know what your
favorite part of the episode was. Was it the
plot or the surprise ending or all the funny
moments.
Overall I thought the episode was brilliant
as expected. It added a lot more context for
the core relationships between Sherlock and
Mycroft and Watson and Mary’s relationship.
I’m always amazed by how good the new actors
are each season.
Amanda Abbington was awesome. And Lars Mikkelsen
was so much fun to watch. I kept having Doctor
Who flashbacks based on his mannerisms and
abilities. I’ll talk more about that during
my breakdown video, but a lot of the credit
goes to redbeard for writing such good characters.
I mean Mark Gatiss. He and steven Moffat are
both responsible for casting, and they said
that they knew mikkelsen was the best choice
for the new villain from the moment they saw
him.
Even though the episode was really intense
it left me with this really strong sense of
optimism for the future of the core characters
and the series in general. To be fair though,
steven moffat already started talking about
series 5. So there was no danger of sherlock
ever going away anytime soon.
Just like last time I’ll be taking 20 of
your questions from the comments tonight and
answering them in a q and a video tomorrow.
I’ll mostly be focusing on episode 3. I
might do a series 4 q and a after I do a predictions
video this week. Be sure to subscribe to get
everything.
The Breakdown video will post on tuesday.
Right now click here to get that q&a video.
I’ll update the annotation when I post the
video. and click here for the breakdown.
Thanks for watching, see you tomorrow! High
Fives!